um so what's it what's the deal with the
logan paul fight cancelled
postponed what's yeah that thing just
didn't say much about that
that thing didn't [ __ ] at all it just
sucked
that's our new segment suck or [ __ ]
so where did you read that that was just
a random
what was that on it's just like all over
instagram that's been postponed
i mean it seems like it like the promo
was kind of quiet on it
yeah pretty pretty wild i mean
here it is right here yeah reports are
the floyd mayweather and logan paul
fight has been postponed due to an
odd lack of interest
i mean it's kind of like i
honestly feel it's not surprising
because i think for no boxing fan
is excited about paul brothers
i think most boxing fans look at paul
brothers like oh they're just youtubers
you know what i mean
yeah yeah it was so i think it was too
weird
yeah you know it wasn't like a circus
match where
let's say logan was a guy
who was like a freak athlete who just
happened to be on youtube
i think people would go oh that would be
crazy i'd be down you know what i mean
because i think it would be from the
angle of competition
yeah but because logan is primarily an
entertainer it that's it's just that
jose can seiko [ __ ] and i think people
are like nah [ __ ] this fool
and i think it just didn't yeah it just
didn't make sense enough
it was too weird it was like people are
like what's gonna happen so much so that
it
loses they lose interest i think it's
that's gonna be it's like i'm not even
gonna tune in it's just gonna be weird
yeah you know and and i also feel it's
i think i think jake
actually may have tipped the scale a
little bit in terms of
people willing to pay to see that kind
of entertainment now
yeah because like with ksi and and logan
it's like their fans want to see them
go at it yeah and they're like equal
like they both started at the same time
it was like they're starting from
an even playing field yeah with this one
it's like just
weird it's like what the [ __ ] gonna
happen i think it's just a big spit in
the face and that pay-per-view structure
i think that
put people off like they looked at that
they're like they're going to make me
pay
double because i didn't buy it now these
guys can go [ __ ] themselves oh
right i forgot about the i think that
was the biggest
[ __ ] yeah it was such a brazen like [ __ ]
you man
hmm yeah so
jake paul's gonna fight uh ben askren
the dude who got kneed by jorge mosbydon
yeah i saw that too i just it's annoying
because ben
askren has like no stand-up at all
his stand-up is garbage complete trash
and
it's totally possible for jake to win
this that's why he's taking the fight
and if he does it he's going to be
ultra annoying god damn whatever
connor talking about it conor looked uh
not great this weekend
oh i know wait we haven't talked about
that right that was on saturday
yeah saturday damn damn dude i'm [ __ ]
i know crazy how uh slow time goes when
you
just when you're sober it's like
it's like the days are so long and the
but it's good it's a good thing i like
it because you can remember it all
that's the
dad well not as much that is like it's
like
as as i get older time goes faster and
so it's nice to slow down and look
yeah and you know things are just like
that seems like forever ago but yeah
saturday connor fought and got his ass
beat i mean it was
so sad like i don't know see him get
that point and then
falling down and that's that face the
face he makes you know that
not him particularly but uh you know
anyone when they're
getting knocked out oh yeah when he
wakes up and he comes to and he realizes
what just happened it's like
ugh you got to feel sad for anyone in
that situation it's like
especially for him where his whole
[ __ ] i mean i right he's worth like
50 million dollars i shouldn't feel too
bad for him
but his whole [ __ ] brand his whole
empire
is is you know rooted in the fact that
he's like overconfident and that's his
image and so then to see him just get
rocked and be
on the ground like just that face is sad
and
defeated it's just like ugh i mean
bro there's a couple of things you could
point out right
um and and this is all kind of like
ethereal [ __ ] i mean i kind of i kind of
agree with chael sohn and he said
you know conor looks slower and i agree
with that
i i don't think he looked as lightning
fast as he used to look
you know that's what made his jose aldo
knockout special that's what made a lot
of his other [ __ ] really special
was he was quick you know wow really
really fast whatever
um or like fast strikes and fast
movement
and i won't go on too long about this
but it's not surprising i mean you know
the dude
took off so much time he's rich as [ __ ]
and that whole
like nice guy [ __ ] going into it i think
that was a cover man i think he was
[ __ ] bricks
when he walked in that ring dude i knew
he was bad
he walked in the ring and he did one of
these he went that was like that anxiety
breath like
oh boy here we go yeah i said the same
thing to kelsey i was like when he was
walking
walking towards the ring i was like he
looks nervous as [ __ ]
it was not it was not like that you know
look at prior conor even connor with
like
you know khabib still he was like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this dude even donald
cerrone
yeah he had a certain level of
confidence he's like i'm gonna murder
this guy
yeah and dustin he's like
oh he's a he's a great competitor i
would love to go a five-round war with
dustin but he's like you know he's
playing nice and all this [ __ ] because
he knows dustin's one of the most
accurate dudes in the game
uh dustin has lost to him before so
dustin
can only gain like
connor should have just gone the
wrestling route you should have just
fought cans he should have
ducked fights made people talk about him
been like i don't need to fight dustin i
beat him once i'll beat him again you
know
[ __ ] prey on people getting angry and
[ __ ]
now yeah yeah
i'm just gonna say it's crazy that um
you know dustin b connor but if he
really wants the belt
if he really wants the title he's got to
fight jake paul yeah he definitely like
jake paul
and that's just wild i mean that's the
thing about fighting is yeah you know
it's just crazy the one thing i will say
is
jake being that [ __ ] first of all a
video of jake
calling out connor he's like i got 10
000 for you cash
i i was know
laughing i was like you look like a nut
bro
like you have millions of dollars but
somehow you look like you've been living
on an island by yourself
like you look fresh off a survivor like
that's how you look like
it just didn't match for me with this
tiny ass teeth
you know i know you know what that you
know what that is to me it's like
it's like the equivalent of someone
sitting
watching tv really loud like connor's
inside his house watching tv really loud
and jake is outside screaming into the
house
but connor just can't hear him because
he's watching tv and he's really
comfortable
and he's watching something he really
enjoys you know and jake's out there
like
dude you [ __ ] lost dude you lost like
he's just screaming into a void no one's
you know what i'm saying
oh man it's like roasting someone who's
never going to see it
here's the thing i'll say though with
like what what's funny is
uh uh jake got on the aerial armani show
and he was
dude he was like boxing is an
art mma is a brawl and i was just dying
some dude was like this is [ __ ] people
said in the 90s
like jake has gone full shill for boxing
it's hilarious like he all of a sudden
he's like against mma
and he's like trying to sell it that
boxing is like you know
he's like [ __ ] he's he's gonna be the
well he'll he'll save boxing he'll save
boxing he'll save it
sorry i agree with what you're saying i
think
i think it's funny like if
if they did box connor would wash him
i think no question he'd wash him well
that's the thing it's like so far from
ever happening maybe i don't know i i
don't know
these guys keep keep uh
blowing up people's expectations so i
don't know we'll see what's up with ben
asking them you know we'll see
how that fight goes oh wait one other
thing i want to say real quick is yeah
i think i think there's like a
there's like a deeper thing about the
dust and connor fight which i think is
great
what and chael brought this up as well
but i've
formed i can safely say i formed this
opinion on my own as well but it's that
you can get in you can get in the gym
you can train
you can do all that hard work you can't
you can do it
but if you're not regularly doing that
[ __ ] like for
competition then it's it's not
it's just not the same like that
fighter mindset you you have to have
like a screw loose to be
in that in that zone okay
and if you're just sort of casually like
100 millionaire
just like yeah i used to fight i knocked
a couple guys out in the last couple
years and i fight man
i'm a good fighter it's not the same as
a dude who's like
yeah i've got like a you know a [ __ ]
sprained rotator cuff and my ankles bad
and yeah
my right hand nerve is [ __ ] up but i'm
still showing up every day and i'm
training because that's
it translates because that whole
training camp like i need to murder this
guy
so i can pay for all the training i just
did yeah
and my [ __ ] mortgage you know that's
that's why
khabib is so scary because you can tell
he just truly does not give a [ __ ] about
the money
or even winning or losing it's all about
honor
it's like yeah it's all it is it's like
i'll [ __ ] kill you
for the honor for for for my family you
know mm-hmm
it's like that's [ __ ] scary that's a
motive right there yeah
yeah i mean like imagine but it's like
sorry go ahead no i mean like imagine
you know how hard conor was [ __ ]
himself i think no one will ever
acknowledge that none of his fans will
acknowledge that conor talked all that
[ __ ]
and then when they locked in he had to
stand on the other side of the cage with
that fool
who's like you died today yeah
yeah and to be beaten to the point where
you go
it's just business please don't kill me
yeah
everyone should have known from that
moment this was a [ __ ] come on
yeah anyway um
okay i just bought my jake paul merch
of fight merch and i'm really excited to
train in it so you know it's just
well yeah because boxing boxing's back
boxing's super back yeah yeah you're
boxing not for
fun you're boxing for to like make
something like you you're it's an
investment
yeah he's definitely gonna fight that's
what i'm saying boxing is coming back
and so this is an investment in
in the future of boxing and um ryan's
toys
uh you know the kids on
um the fine bros react channel
okay uh who else
uh jojo siwa yeah yeah okay and
any anyone nine years old and or nine to
four
jojo c was like a teenager but yeah he's
actually like a full adult but
maybe not her because he's kind of
athletic so you know any like nine to
12 year old that's that's what i'm
gunning for in 2022.
yeah i'll box anyone on the trending
page
yourself yeah what do you mean what does
that mean
like i can box
oh so you'll box any like bryce hall
maybe not those maybe not them why you
scared
they're on [ __ ] steroids do we
confirm that
yeah that doesn't mean they know how to
punch or move they still beat my ass
probably
no yeah wait till i get my peloton [ __ ]
wait till i
put in hours on the peloton i'm i'm
strictly speaking about this
[ __ ] game on yeah no in a street
fight they they'd wash this easily
yeah palm our heads and ram it into a
trash can
we're just running it yeah full speed
full speed yeah
you